não vai ficar assim olha o tempo não o
jovem engenho e aí galera se perguntando
você está bem está tudo bom que bom que
estou um pouco chateado porque eu
comprei lá chamado iphone o que acontece
com o teste não sei mexer nessa bosta
foi botar música e chicão já tem que
botar no godoy doni tem que ligar não
sei o que botar senso de quem tem que
falar com steve jobs nunca apareça lá
complicação e pra mim que sou burro pior
em com saudade de emergência em caso de
ter que foi que eu fiz eu peguei a parte
de música do meu outro celular passei
por computador e passei todas a música
do jeito que tava pra essa luta quando
você sincroniza o programa life dunes
consolar a música vão do jeitinho que
está lá no céu também que não tem
organização feito eu o tomei no aí eu
fui viajar como é que ele vai viajar
botafogo de ouvido
só tiro foi ouvido na hora que chegou no
destino é só problema disso tudo é que a
gente tem um custo de ter cinco mil
músicas no seu lado a gente escutar 5
resultado eu escutei músicas que eu nem
sabia que tinha no meu celular eu não
sei nem com a música foi para lá
resultado teve que escutar todas as
músicas tá nessa hora eu vou pegar
algumas dessas músicas vou comentar
agora essa música que música caranguejo
do latim gol mas na página volta jamais
quem vive de passado é museu caranguejo
quem anda prata gente por favor por
favor me diga aonde desgraça é que o
caranguejo onda pra trás e assim não sei
aonde eu vivo né no mundo no caso que eu
saiba o caranguejo ele anda pulado para
trás nem vivem de passado é museu
michael jackson que anda cá atrás
até aqui a música do victor leo que vida
boa ou o que vida boa
sapo caiu na lagoa sou eu no caminho do
meu sertão
a vida boa ea pessoa no caminho sertão
entendo mas eu eu nem com que eu não
consigo entender
eu não consigo compreender se extrair da
música é o que tem a ver o sapucaí na
gols a personalidade natural da capital
italiana é tas à pana que tem um sabor
canela gol deixou a sapucaí na lagoa
para outra música que tinha larga também
tem 10 como the head e uma garrafa de
tequila e hoje estou pagando pra você e
sua amiga aí as mina pira e vai pirar
quando eu falar que eu sou amigo do
neymar que a gente vê um alto caso de
preconceito cara acha que ele vai ser
mais bem tratar só porque ele é amigo do
neymar que ainda têm alguma vaga naquela
festa lá é de chuva
quem não viu tá certo oi telemar e aí
aparece a editar a aí que o senhor é
abalar e cunhou essl bicho eu acho que
sobrou do convite para a festa ainda
agora vem a música que eu não entendo o
que essa música estava fazendo meus a
oeste bem atenção para você não perder a
filosofia e o poema que essa música fala
baixo de filosofia agora que essa luta é
essa música essa música um poema eu sei
que você já é casado mas me diz o que
fazer porque quando a troca tem dona é
que vem a vontade de futuro então mama
pega no meu e mama chama de plena cama a
minha
quero te dar quero te dar essa música do
mister catra em participação da valesca
popozuda quando eles quando escuta a
música me sinto bem porque essa música
essa música é essa música é quase gospel
dessa música sem vontade de fazer uma
oração ou até falar onde estava com
depressão estava com vontade de tentar o
suicídio o teste música passo para essa
música tem um bocado de música estando a
falar agora porque esse tipo de música é
muito fácil mas gosto muito fácil como é
que faz a música sertaneja é também o
sertanejo você cantar com força e bombom
tem gente que tem cheiro de rosas de
avelã você tento num a quituteira que da
transmídia na voz é também o funk faz
com que qualquer por ter sua frente do
iphone e vai carregando a pega no
caminho do iphone
ai ai ai meu deus ai ai se eu tocar no
fome zero que é campeão pega né no
caminho da escola é o arroz que com a
rock pra dançar arrocha como se você
tivesse uma coisa mal resolvida no curto
enquanto você dança você gosta
a galera gosta de falar senão mas as
músicas de hoje também é que as músicas
de hoje por exemplo é na música de
criança tem coisas que a gente não
consegue entender e tai hoje resolveu
passar a tarde até desgraça estamos hoje
e domingo pede cachimbo que chama de
ouro bate no turu turu e valente bater
na gente a gente é faca no buraco que
fica com ciúme e fala onde é que existe
um pé de cachimbo ainda mais de ouro
agora me diz o que o cachimbo de ouro e
batendo torto tem mais com o que se
entende aquela brincadeira que a gente
gosta de brincar também interesses e
vitamina c vai começar o chá chá chá era
uma velha fora até ela caiu no meio fio
o velho viu assim a tela verde amarelo
do brasil
o material vai ser a velha europa até
agora você vai colocar até mesa agora
que desgraça no mundo é cor o cotel ea
borboletinha está na cozinha fazer
chocolate para madrid e até aí beleza tá
borboleta fazendo chocolate com a
madrinha dela coisa que todo mundo faz
nenhuma deixa aqui na minha casa e faz
chocolate é agora o tipo ç perna de pau
ou dividiu na área e [ __ ] pau é que eu
não entendo a pessoa que tem perna de
pau ou divinamente picapau essa pessoa
estava ajeitando taeko vivemos a parede
quer dizer se a pessoa está sofrendo
agora o que explicar uma coisa pra vocês
galera não existe música não existe uma
música que não é pra você a prepara que
agora é hora do show das poderosas meu
deus que música idiotas eu prefiro ouvir
caetano veloso gilberto gil e você tem o
seu gosto você tem cultura e gosta de
música boa agora porque não dá pra fazer
é pegar caetano veloso gilberto gil toca
na balada então um da nep existem
existem músicas que são para o momento
certo da vida pré para que o show das
poderosas pela mãe solteira que é pra
falar que quer pegar todo mundo sabe que
caiu na lagoa ou vida boa vida boa
sacada na lagoa victor e leo pessoa mais
tranqüila pessoas que querem o campo
talvez a música entende de criança
porque só assim com a palavra que não
existe porque criança criança na hora de
viajar então quando a música for ruim
separa de ouvir ela vai o dia que você
gosta é porque você não gosta da música
que é ruim é que ela não foi feita pra
você que olha só a imagem mudou mais uma
vez em porquê porque a bactéria idiota
da câmara acabou
e aí fiquei com o breve mas agora eu tô
aqui pra dar pra vocês já que está
falando sentindo
musica o que vocês conhecessem o canal
da ísis que é uma colega minha que faz
os vi muita hora os negócios de comer
tal e é muito interessante ela vai dar
um recado agora pra vocês
e aí galera que curte widerson o meu
nome é isis e eu tenho um canal de
música então há certa aí pra ir pro meu
canal e se inscrever nele dá uma olhada
lá se você quiser conhecer o canal dayse
inscrevê lá eu particularmente eu gosto
eu dou light
clique aqui para escrever enquanto você
está se inscrevendo no canadá e se eu
que sou índio do futuro
já estou editando esse vídeo ilícito no
passado ainda vai ter uma coisa pra
falar pra vocês eu tô aqui igual aqueles
caras que jogam minecraft mas muito
obrigado você está assistindo esse vídeo
agora vamos lutar muito do passado vamos
lá muito do passado é com você
[Música]
agora eu quero saber de você coloca bem
aqui em baixo os comentários qual é a
música que você mais gosta comenta e
pode começar a música preferida ou doido
disse pra mim que estava saindo daqui
sem clicar em gosto e se fernando não
foi o ps e foi transformado em sabão de
coco na placa não gostei que ajuda muita
gente você está no facebook daquela
velha curtir dos blogs é a primeira vez
que estava em um vídeo meu clique em
inscrever-se aqui porque aí quando tiver
de novo você vai saber idéia e tanque e
falou ninguém vai levantar foto comigo
vamos dar um voto comigo dando uma volta